ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะถ้าพบกับลูกฟ้า
แล้วก็คงเอกนะคะ
ไงดีกินเด้อขา
เฮงโอเควันที่เนาะน่ารักที่จะนะคะแป๊บนึง
วันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครูฟ้าจะให้กูอีกแค่
สกีหรือผู้ฟ้าแชร์อ่ากูพระเชได้
ลอง
โอเคอ๋อโอเค
วันนี้
อ่ะ
ขอกำลังงงนะฮะไม่เคยเข้าไปที่นี่
วันนี้วันที่
วันวันอะไรนะวันอะไรคะเสือป่าวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะหนังสุขให้คุยเขียนหรือเปล่าผมไป
พูดอ่านเขียนได้ไหมเลยเขียนก็ได้เขียนควร
จะได้พูด
วันนี้วันศุกร์ราคา
วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 28 ค่ะวันที่ 28
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคม
ปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
5 นะคะพี่ข้อศ.เท่าไหร่คะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา
17:00 น 36 นาที
4  36 นาทีครูฟ้ากับครูเอกก็จะพูดพูดจน
ถึง
6  6 โมง 6 โมง 6 นาทีเนาะนะคะก็ 30
นาทีพูดโอเคค่ะเว้นรอบแล้วนะคะ
ลบๆ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าคู่ฟ้า
มีไอ้ฟ้าจะวาดรูปหรือว่ามีรูปให้ดูคะวัน
นี้เนี่ยกูป๊าจะมีอ่า Sorry มาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฟังนะคะผู้หญิงแฟนน่าจะวาดที่นี่
หรือให้ครู a  Share  screen ของคลีดี
กูพาว่าที่นี่ก็เอกคิดว่าอะไรดีกว่ากันกู
อีกว่าจะดีดีกว่าโอเคปิดก็ได้ค่ะเพราะว่า
ถ้ารูปเมื่อกี้กูเอกกลัวกูฟ้าหายไปอีก
เนี่ยได้ครับโอเคค่ะในคลิปที่แล้วปลูกฟ้า
กับปุ๋ยหายมีแต่รูปมาอ้าโอเคงั้นเดี๋ยว
ครูฟ้าว่าที่
ปรีดี
โหลดอยู่โอเค
มาละ
[เพลง]
นอกวันนี้จะเล่านิทานใช่ไหมวันนี้จะเล่า
นิทานค่ะคุณเอ๋ทานคืออะไรค่ะนิทานก็คือ
เป็น Sorry นะคะที่มีคนสำหรับเด็กๆเด็ก
นี่อายุเท่าไหร่คะอีกผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้ชายอายุประมาณ
1 ขวบฟังรู้สึก 3  3 ขวบภาษาขวบ
3-4
13-10 ไหมอายุ 31
มาถึงปิด 12  2 กะนาย
นิทานหาเป็น Story ที่เอาไว้เล่าให้เด็กๆ
ฟังเด็กๆฟังนะเราให้เด็กฟังค่ะก็จะเป็น
นิทานนะคะปกติเวลาเล่านิทานเนี่ยเขาจะพูด
อะไรนะมันสุพรอาร์ไทร์ใช่รักครั้งหนึ่งณ
วรรณสุพรเดอะทายราคาหนึ่งนานมาแล้วมีนี้
ให้คู่ความจะมาต่อใช่ไหมใส่หานิทานเรื่อง
นี้อ่ะ
นักเรียนน่าจะ
รู้จัก
นี้อ่อนนักเรียนรู้จักใส่ฮะก็กาลครั้ง
หนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
นานๆโอเคน้อง
แล้วมี
หมู่บ้านหลังนึงนะคะบ้าอะไรประกาหาย
มีบ้าน
อามีบ้าน 1 หลัง
บ้าน 1 หลังค่ะ
เป็นบ้าน 1 หลังอยู่ในป่า
ป่าก็ต้องมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้มากๆ
ป้านะ
เห็นเด็กโอเคค่ะมี
คุณแม่
ถึงแม่นะคะ
แม่กับลูกสาวมีคุณแม่แล้วก็มีลูกสาว
คุณหนาวคุณพ่อมีไหมก็
ถ้าไม่มีอ๋อมีคุณแม่กับลูกสาว
มีอยู่
2 คนใช่มั้ยคุณแม่ลูกสาวนะคะ 2 คนอ่ะไม่
มีคุณพ่อนี่คุณแม่กับลูกสาวแล้วก็อยู่ที่
บ้านนะคะเป็นเด็กกำพร้าพ่อพ่อคุณพ่อตาย
เหรอคะให้ค่ะคุณพ่อตายเพราะ Mac มีก็มีก็
ต้องอยู่ที่บ้านกับคุณแม่นะฮะค่ะอ้าวแล้ว
ปกติใหทุกวันวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธมัน
ก็ได้วันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ทุกวัน
ทุกวันทำไมคะมีอะไรคุณแม่ก็จะทำอาหาร
ทำอาหาร
สปาเก็ตตี้แฮมเบอร์เกอร์
fit  and  zip ทำ
พี่พายแอพเปิ้ลนาคุณแม่ทำสละทำอาหารชายทำ
อาหารนะคะหรือว่าทำเค้กทำคุกกี้ทำขนมค่ะ
ทำขนมเนี่ยให้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงเนี่ยอ๋อเอา
อุ้ยเด็กๆหนูน้อยหมวกแดงเหรอคะเด็กเด็กคน
นี้ไม่ได้ชื่อหนูน้อยหมวกแดงค่ะแต่ว่า
เด็กคนนี้จะมีแฟชั่นนะเดี๋ยวกูพาว่าจน
นั้น
วันนี้มีมีผ้าคลุมนะคะด่าก็ใส่เหมือนมั่ว
ใช่มะม่วง
เป็นฝรั่ง
แล้วก็จะมี
ถึงเป็น Good ใช้หนี้
อ่าอันนี้เนี่ยสีแดง
สีแดงเอกช่วยไหมคะ
อยากคุยโอเค
แข็งแรงขอชอบบิดใส่เป็นเสื้อคลุมภาษาซื้อ
Chrome
เพื่อกลุ่มตรงนี้นะไม่เป็นไรค่ะนี่ว่าให้
ดู
เป็นสีแดงใช่ไหมเด็กผู้หญิงนะคะเป็นเด็ก
ผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อคลุม
กูเองมีกลุ่มแล้วครูฟ้าแต่ว่า
สีแดงไหมสีเทาอ้าวหนีเขาอ่ะโอเค
ได้ป่วยในเสื้อคลุมใช่มั้ย vacuum
มีสีเทา
โอเคนะแล้วก็ตรงนี้ปิดผมปิดหัวเออ
อะไรนี้ของเด็กๆเป็นสีแดงสีแดงสีเทาโอเค
ให้เสื้อคลุมเนี่ยมีมั่วกับมีหมวกหมวกกบ
ไปหมวก
หัว
สีเทาโอเคค่ะคุณหญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยสีแดงค่ะคนอื่นๆ
เวลาเห็นก็เลยเรียกว่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดงอ๋อ
เพราะว่าหมวกสีแดงหมวกสีแดงใช่ค่ะเข้าใจ
ใช่คุณแม่ก็จะบอกให้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงใช่
มั้ยหนูน้อยหมวกแดงคุณแม่ทำอาหาร
อ่ะค่ะให้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงเนี่ยเอาอาหารไป
ให้คุณยายพ่อ
คุณแม่ก็มีคุณแม่
ชายเฮียอันนี้คุณแม่ใช่ไหมค่ะ
คุณพ่อ
อันนี้หนูน้อยมดแดงแกงเขียนติดหมวกแดง
แล้วคุณแม่เนี่ยก็จะมี
มีคุณพ่อกับคุณแม่ใช่ก็พอมั้งคุณตาคุณยาย
ใช่ไหมคะๆหานี้คุณตาอันนี้คุณยายอ่ะค่ะ
คุณตาคุณยายนะคะค่ะคุณแม่เดี๋ยวก็ทำอาหาร
นะทำอาหารไม่
อยู่น้อยหมวกแดงเอาอ่ะเอาไปให้คุณยายเอา
แล้วคุณตาล่ะให้คุณตาคะปลายแล้วค่ะอ๋อคุณ
ตายแล้วก็มีคุณแม่คุณยายนะคะเอ้าคุณยาย
ไม่ได้อยู่บ้าน
มายอ่ะเดียวกันไหม
นี่เดี๋ยวพนักงานรบกัน
คุณบ้านที่นี่แหละมีแค่คุณแม่ใช่ไหมกับ
หนูน้อยหมวกแดง
[เพลง]
ส่วนคุณยาย
ต้องเข้าไปในป่า
เข้าไปในป่านะคะก็จะมีป่า
ช่วยคุ้ม
เสื้อขึ้นกูเห็นนอนป่าป่า
บ้านยายในอยู่ที่นี่ขอยืนอยู่อยู่ในป่า
อยู่ในป่าแล้วก็จะมีคุณยาย
ยายอยู่กับใครคะ
คุณยายเนี่ยอยู่คนเดียวค่ะเดียวนะคะอยู่
คนเดียวเออคุณแม่ก็เหมือนเดิมทำอาหารทำ
เค้กอ่ะอาจจะเป็นพายแอพเปิ้ล
ให้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงคุณแม่บอกว่าอ่ะหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงเอาอาหารไปให้คุณยายนะ
ให้เดินตรงไปบ้านคุณยายใช่ไหมอาหารเดินๆ
มาบ้านคุณยายค่ะห้ามคุยกับคนที่ไม่รู้จัก
คะเดินไปมีคนเห็นอ่ะหนูน้อยหมวกแดงสวัสดี
แก้คำพูดคำพูด
ห้ามคุยกับคนที่ไม่รู้จักเคยเห็นมาบ้าน
คุณแม่คุยกับคุณแม่พูดได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะได้
แต่ถ้าชอบให้รู้จักใช้ใครใครอันนี้ข้าม
พูดในฮะไม่รู้ว่าชื่ออะไรใช่ไหมไม่รู้ว่า
ชื่ออะไรห้ามพูด
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็บอกว่าโอเค
โอเคแม่แล้วหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็เดินเดินๆ
เข้าไม่ได้ป่าจ๊ะในป่าค่ะ
มารบหนูน้อยหมวกแดงใหญ่มาก
คุณเอามาให้หน่อยค่ะอาหารใช่ฮะอาหารก็จะ
เป็น
ตักราดใช่ไหมค่ะอ่ะ
ร้านอาหารมันจะมีอะไรช่างใน Apple  Pie
ให้ปิดเอาไว้
อาหารนี้เป็นตะกร้านะคะแล้วหมูแดงก็ถือ
ตะกร้า
แล้วก็เดินเดินเดินเข้ามาในป่าเดินไป
ตอนกำลังเดินไปหนูโหลดไป
เจอเธออะไรคะหมาป่าค่ะพี่เอ๋
หมาป่า
ไม่ใช่อันนี้มาบ้าน
นี้มาบ้านนะฮะหมาป่าป่าก็
มาฝากใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
แล้วก็จะมีฟันมีเขี้ยวหมีเขี้ยวหมีเขี้ยว
หมาป่าน่าจะหิว
ใช่หมาป่าน่าจะหิวนะคะอ่ะอานิหมาป่า
หมาป่า
มะป่านี่
บาทที่บ้านไว้แล้วบอกว่าเหรอ
ครับอ่านี่เวลาเวลาพระจันทร์แต่นะคะ
อาจารย์นี่มั้ย
ประวัติแย่มากเลยเวลาที่ที่พระจันทร์
อะกรีวัดให้ก็ได้ดำนะคะ
พระจันทร์น่ะ
พระจันทร์
ไปเป็นพระจันทร์เต็มดวง
คันจันทร์เปลี่ยนเป็นพรมกลมๆสว่างมาปากขน
หมาป่ามันแบบ
โอเคเจอมาแต่ถ้านะคะให้หมาป่าก็จะเห็นหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงหมาป่าก็เลยถามว่าข่าวจังหวัด
อะไรอบรับทายสวัสดี
มาทำอะไรในป่า
อันดับเอาหมาป่าพูดได้ค่ะหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
พูดกับหมาป่าไหมคะหนูน้อยหมวกแดงพูดกับ
หมาป่าค่ะอ๋อพูดว่าอะไร
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงบอกว่าสวัสดี
ฉันกำลังไปเยี่ยมคุณยาย
ไปหาคุณยายเออที่บ้านคุณยายอ๋อใกล้
[เพลง]
หรือจะมาหาคุณยายคุณยาย
ที่บ้านนะที่บ้าน
ใช่หมาป่าก็คิด
ก็ตอนแรกเนี่ยหมาป่าจะกิน
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงนะแต่หนูน้อยหมวกแดงบอกหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงไปหาคุณยาย
ก็เลยคิดว่าหมาป่าจะกิน
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงแล้วก็กิน
คุณยายด้วยกิน 2 คนเลยกินสองคนเลยค่ะอิ่ม
มากๆนะชายมาปากเล็กพี่นะทำไมกินสองคน
มาป่าก็เลยบอกหนูน้อยหมวกแดงว่า
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงไปหาคุณยายต้องมีดอกไม้
ด้วยอ๋อดอกไม้นะคะเขาว่าดอกไม้กันดอกไม้
ดอกไม้ใช่มั้ย
แล้วดอกไม้อยู่ที่ไหนดอก
ดอกไม้ดอกไม้เนี่ยอยู่ในป่าค่ะอยู่ในป่า
อย่างนี้เลยอ่ะดอกไม้ดอกไม้
ไม่ใช่อยู่ไม่ใช่อยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมพรุ่ง
นี้ไม่มีไม่มีต้องเดินเดินเข้าไปในป่ามือ
กันเดินตื่นๆ
นี้ใช่
ก็ต้องเดินเข้าไปในป่า
หมาป่าก็บอกให้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงเดินเข้าไป
ในป่านะคะไปเก็บดอกไม้
แดงไปไหมคะดูหน้าหมูแดงก็ไปค่ะ
ก็เดินเข้าไปในป่าหมาป่าก็เลยรีบวิ่งมา
ที่บ้านคุณยายมาผัดไก่คะบ้านคุณยายค่ะไป
ที่บ้านคุณยายใช่แวะมาที่บ้านคุณยายแล้ว
ก็ทำอะไร
กับคุณยายทำ
ต้องรบกวนไหมกูบอกว่าต้องลบเคลียร์กันนะ
คะ
เคลียร์ตัวเองอะไร
อันนี้เป็นที่บ้านคุณยายใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็น
เตียงให้
[เพลง]
เตียงนอนเตียงนอน
อันนี้จะเป็นตู้ค่ะตู้เสื้อผ้าเหรอคะในหา
ตู้เสื้อผ้าเสื้อเสื้อผ้า
หมาป่าก็เลยวิ่งมาที่บ้านคุณยายก็กับคุณ
ยายไม่ได้ตู้เสื้อผ้ายังไม่ได้กินนะใช่
อ๋ออ๋อ
อย่า
จับใหญ่ใส่ตู้เสื้อผ้าหน้าแล้วหมาป่าก็
ใส่เสื้อผ้าคุณยายโอเคอ้าเอกเป็นหมาป่าไป
อ่า
คุณยายหรอกช่วยด้วยช่วยด้วยนะไม่หามาป่า
น่าจะมีอ่ะเป็นปากไว้ติดปากใหญ่ไว้
แล้วมาป่าวก็ขึ้นไปนอน
บนเตียงหรอคะๆหามาป่าก็ขึ้นมานอนบนเตียง
แล้วก็
อีกตัวเองใช่ไหม
เอามานิเฟอร์เลิฟๆก็นอนบนเตียงนอนละ
ถึงเวลาหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็มาที่บ้านค่ะอ่ะ
อ่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็เลยเดินเข้ามาหาคุณ
ยาย
เห็นคุณยายนอนอยู่ไอ้ผู้ใหญ่นอนอยู่หมา
ป่าใช่ไหมมาป่านอนมาฟ้านอน
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็
ถาม
คุณยายว่าคุณยายที่เป็นหมาป่านะคะถามว่า
อะไรคะคุณยายคะ
ทำไมคุณยายต้อง
นอนคลุมด้วยคะนอนละใช้ผ้าคลุมไหล่ผ้าคลุม
หน้าคงอยู่อกงแบบตัว a อ่ะแบบเก๋ตรงทำไม
ต้องใช้ผ้าคลุมด้วยคะมะปาตอบว่าหมาป่าตอบ
ว่ายายไม่สบาย
เดี๋ยวกูเองเป็นมาปะ
สบาย
ยายหนาวยายไม่
รู้สิฉี่ a มาในนิยายหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็ถาม
อีกว่ากลับว่าอะไรคุณยายคะ
ทำไมเสียงของคุณยาย
แปลกจังเลยคะเสียงเสียงได้เจ็บคอใช่ไหม
โอ๋ใช่
ยายเจ็บ
ยายเจ็บคอ
ไปขอขอ
อันนี้พอข้างในก็พูดคอบางที
เจ็บคอ
ม้า
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงเจ็บคอถามอีกว่าคุณยายคะ
ทำไมคุณยายถึงมีเขี้ยว
มีเขี้ยว
โอ้ทำไมคุณยายถึงมีเขี้ยวยาวขนาดนั้นหมา
ป่าตอบว่าอะไรคะ
หมาปากบอกว่า
ยายมีเขี้ยวก็เพราะๆเอาไว้จับ
หลานกินยังไงล่ะงดจับหลานกินกู
มาปากก็
ให้บับอ้าก็เอาผ้าออกใช่
[ปรบมือ]
ไหมกูวิ่งไปจะจับหนูน้อยหมวกแดงจับได้นะ
คะหนูนะหมู่ใดก็กรี๊ด
เสียงดัง
เออก็เลยมีช่วยดุล
ใช่ช่วยด้วย
ก็เลยมีผู้ชาย 1 คนค่ะ
วิ่งเข้ามานะผู้ชาย
ผู้ชาย 1 คนและ
คะแล้วก็มีปืนนักแม่นปืนด้วยหรอมีปืนใช่
มีปืนปืน
ประวัติยินบ่คุยปืน
ปืนเหมือนไดร์เป่าผมปืน
หายปืนหาปืนยิงปืนเข้ามาแล้วก็เลยยิ่งหมา
ป่าตั้งเจ๋งตั้งโดนหมาป่าไหมคะโดนหาโดน
หมาป่าและป่าร้องอะไรโอ๊ยเลอะ
มาป๋าร้องโอ๊ยใช่มั้ยโอ้ย
โอ๊ย
แล้วหมาป่าก็ตาย
ตายหรอ
งั้นหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็ไม่เป็นอะไรนั่นเป็น
ข้างๆคุณยายอยู่ที่ไหนคุณยังเพลงอยู่ที่
ไหน
ก็เลยหาโทรหาคุณยายค่ะแล้วก็เจอคุณยาย
อยู่ในตู้เสื้อผ้าภาพเปิดตู้อาหารไอห่า
แล้วหมูแดงก็เลย
เปิดตู้เสื้อผ้า
จะมี
เปิดตู้เสื้อผ้าก็พาคุณยายเนี่ยออกมา
รักคุณยายออกมา
เองแล้วดูน้ำหมูแดงก็เลยคุยกับคุณยาย
บอกว่าขอโทษค่ะคุณยายขอโทษเรื่องอะไร
เรื่องที่หนูน้อยหมวกแดงคุยกับคนไม่รู้
จักค่ะว่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดงไม่รู้จักหมาป่า
ค่ะคุณแม่ห้ามพูดใช่ไหมหาผมคุยมีมุ้งห้าม
คุยกับคนไม่รู้จักค่ะว่าสัตว์นะ
หนูแต่หนูว่าหมึกแดงได้คุยกับหมาป่า
ทำให้หมาป่าเนี่ย
มีบ้านคุณยายใช่ไหมรู้
ชายหาดยายก็เลยบอกว่า
ยายไม่โกรธขออย่าให้รู้นะไม่โกรธนะผู้
ใหญ่ใจดีตายห่าแต่ว่า
ดูนะมุกแดงต้องห้ามคุยกับคนแปลกหน้าอีก
[เพลง]
จำไว้ว่าอย่านะห้ามคุยกับคนแปลกหน้าค่ะ
เวลาอ่าเพราะว่าถ้าคุยกับคนแปลกหน้าแล้ว
บอกใช่ไหมบอกทั้งหมดบางทีคนที่แปลกหน้า
คือคนไม่รู้จักอ่าชิดไม่ใช่มั้ยฮะคิดไม่
ดี
รักก็จะน่ากลัวนะคะน่ากลัว
ยังหมาขาลูกค้ากับครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่ใช่คน
แปลกหน้าใช่ไหมคะ
วันนี้ไม่ใช่อ่ะตอนนี้ไว้
ไม่ใช่นะเออสิ 4 ปีไหม 4 ปีที่แล้ว
มีที่แล้วอาจจะแปลกหน้านิดหน่อยแต่ก็ไม่
แปลกหน้าเพราะว่าอ่ะอ่าเดี๋ยวไปว่าอันนี้
คุณพ่อ
มีคุณพ่อครูคว้าคุณแม่ครูฟ้าคุณพ่อมีน้อง
สาวไอ้น้ำโขงฟ้า
ครูเอ๋นิโครเอ๋ทำให้ครูฟ้า
รู้จักคุณอาอา
อ่าของครูฟ้ารัฐเป็นพ่อ
แม่อา
ของครูฟ้าครูเอ๋รู้จักอ่ะงานเนี่ยก็ไม่
ใช่คนแปลกหน้า
แต่ถ้ากูเอกเดินเดินๆที่ถนน
เดินเดินเดินที่ถนนครูฟ้าครูเอ๋เจอกันไม่
รู้จักกันเนี้ยคนแปลกหน้า
แต่ครูเอ๋รู้จักคุณอาครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอ่ะ
เห็นผู้เหตุนาบอกอันนี้อาเห
[เพลง]
ล็งหน้าคนพ่อแม่ไม่รู้จะถ้าเราไม่รู้จัก
ไม่รู้จักนะคะไม่พูดหนี
ใช่เด็กนะคะตั้งหนี
ตัวนะคะเฮ้ยเคงั้นวันนี้คือฟ้ากับครูเอก
ก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะถ้าทรายไปก่อนหมดเวลา
แล้วนะคะก่อนจากไปอย่าลืมอะไรคะครูฟ้าก็
จะไปอย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด Subscribe
นะคะนักเรียน
เจอตั๊ดวีดีโอหน้า
อาทิตย์หน้าโอเค
สวัสดีค่ะถ้า